this video sponsored by squarespace the
best way to make an amazing website
it has never been more difficult to
choose between an 11 inch
and a 12.9 inch ipad pro especially
since
apple has supercharged these with the
new m1 chip that supports thunderbolt
we have new software that's coming out
and of course now
you have to choose not only based on
size but if you want an lcd display
or if you want the new mini led xdr
screen
but by the end this video i will make
this choice
easy for you because today we're going
to cover everything from performance and
thermal throttling
to the speaker differences and of course
look at the displays
to tell you which one you should buy but
before we jump in i want to give a shout
out to the sponsor of this video
squarespace
if you've been thinking about making
your own website squarespace is
seriously the best way to go
you can build a great looking website
like we did with literally no web making
experience
and it doesn't matter if you want a
portfolio a blog e-commerce or anything
else you just simply choose a template
and customize blocks of text and images
and then easily move them around it's
incredibly simple it's affordable and
ours have been running flawlessly for
over three years now
bringing in tons of traffic thanks to
its built-in seo tools start your free
two-week trial with no credit card
required by going to squarespace.com
maxtec or by using the custom link down
below and when you're ready to launch
you'll save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain let's start out with the size
and the weight in hand as you guys could
tell
there is a big difference between these
two when you look online it's hard to
tell
and even just using the 12.9 inch like i
did in the earlier video
it seemed fine it seemed you know like a
decent size
not that much bigger but when you put
these side by side oh my goodness the
difference is
dramatically noticeable now the other
thing that i could tell is that the 12.9
inch
it not only feels a lot heavier
noticeably heavier in the hand
it feels thicker as well now i've
personally always wanted the smaller
size ipads and i've used the ipad pro
for hours
in my hand without any issues but
holding
the 12.9 inch and using it i feel like
after maybe a half hour an hour
depending on which muscle you have you
your arm and your hand will get tired of
holding it out in the air like this but
along with that it really depends on
what you want to do with your ipad if
you're just using simple apps you're
looking at photos
you're doing some web browsing this
extra screen doesn't really add a lot
because you can only read
one thing at a time and with that as
well
if you're doing things like photo
editing you may think that oh
i need the larger display but taking a
look at this i'm not getting much more
compared to
the 11 inch if you have creators like
adobe
and they're making applications that are
optimized they make them really nice so
where i really have
no issue using them on the smaller ipad
i can see my photo
i can zoom in and out i can adjust all
the sliders they're designed really well
look the menu bar goes away right there
the 11 inch has no
issue with that but if you're somebody
that wants to do things
like video editing for example running
lumafusion
here even with this larger ipad once you
have
things like your different layers
applied and this is a very simple
timeline you guys can see how much
smaller
the actual viewer is and then if we go
ahead and open that up
on the smaller one that's where it gets
really tough look how small that is
right there
and this is even a simple project you
can get crazy with a lot of different
layers
and this for example video editing is
when i would really want to have
the larger 12.9 inch and if you're
somebody that often draws or creates and
you want to have a larger canvas
or if you're a pro user and you want to
do the split screen
that is where the 12.9 inch model really
comes in handy so as far as which one to
choose based
on size i would say for somebody that
mainly uses an ipad
as an ipad you run different apps maybe
play some games
you watch videos and then you do some
productivity the 11 inch ipad is
definitely the better one
the 12.9 right now i've been holding it
for a little over an hour my hand is
getting really tired
but if you're a professional you're
making the most out of your ipad you're
doing a lot of productivity
then i say the 12.9 inch is the better
choice but that is just
based on the screen size we have a lot
more to cover and before we cover those
things such as the thermal throttling
with the smaller chassis
and the display we have to mention
keyboard cases
we have apple's new white magic keyboard
case
and not only does it 12.9 inch you know
it's bulkier it's heavier
when you add on this keyboard case it
adds on a dramatic amount
of thickness and weight so now this
thing
weighs quite a bit more than the 11 inch
one
with that keyboard case and i know for
some people if you buy something that's
big and heavy for example a dslr camera
or even a 16-inch macbook pro
if it's inconvenient if it's heavy a lot
of times you leave it at home
and then if you buy something like a
macbook air or the smaller combo here
you're much more likely to take it with
you so you have to keep that in mind
now as far as the actual keyboards
themselves
with that larger display you do have
larger keys
so this feels a little bit more cramped
i have used this extensively and you do
get used to it
but with the 12.9 inch this is a
full-size keyboard just like on a mac
so you are going to have a more familiar
typing experience it is going to feel a
little bit better and along with that we
have two more differences with these
cases the first one is how much room it
takes up
i was just on an airplane i was doing a
lot of editing and having this larger
one that
sits up much higher it doesn't give you
a lot of room
if you're on the little tiny tray table
and if somebody leans back
it doesn't work well where the 11 inch
it's actually perfect
for people that fly unless you can
always pay for first class
now the other difference is if you're
somebody likes to use your device on
your lap the 11 inch is more balanced
and it sits flatter it's not as wobbly
just maybe because it's more compact
overall and it works well
even though you would think that this
larger one would sit better
it's actually very top heavy just
because of how heavy the ipad itself is
and so i don't know i don't think the
experience is as good
for people that type this way and now
it's time to compare the speakers both
of these have quad speakers which is
great
but the larger ipad has them spread a
little bit further apart
and there's a potential that apple made
better use of this larger chassis
to make it sound better so we're going
to test that out along with that we have
this new song so i want you guys to let
me know
what you think of this new song compared
to our previous one
if you have headphones put them on and
let's go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down below and also if you guys enjoyed
this new song if we should stick with it
to give you my opinion i have to say i'm
really surprised
i was not expecting the new one to sound
that much better
not only is it louder which i expected
to be a little bit louder but the bass
is much more deep and rich that doesn't
mean that the 11
sounds bad it sounds excellent for a
tablet but
if you care about sound quality and
loudness if you're watching movies
listening to music
the 12.9 inch is definitely better and
now let's cover the cameras and
microphones and the good news is that
they are identical between both so that
doesn't force you to choose one over the
other
the rear camera is the same this front
camera is this crazy
ultra wide so you guys can see that top
camera right there both of them get the
center stage
feature no differences and now let's get
into performance now i typically
wouldn't be doing this
but with the new m1 chip that's ultra
powerful the larger 12.9 inch model
could get better performance because it
has better cooling
than the 11 inch so i'm very curious i
am going to start out with geekbench 5
i'm gonna hit run actually before that
you guys can see that both of these do
have eight gigs of ram
we also do have one that's still
completely sealed that has 16 gigs
so we're going to do a dedicated video
doing multiple different
real life stress tests with different
productivity tasks to see if the 16 gig
gives you any more performance in the 8
gig
if you guys want to see that click that
subscribe button down below and that
also helps us
to reach our goal of getting 1 million
subscribers before the end of the year
we would greatly appreciate it alright
look at that
the 11 inch actually was done slightly
faster
and it does actually have a slightly
higher score
it's nice seeing that over 1700 but in
reality the scores are almost identical
now before i do a much more difficult
test that's
much longer i also want to go ahead and
benchmark the graphics so both these
have the a
core graphics units of where from the m1
so instead of 7 core gpu
it's great that apple did put in the 8
core units and there you go
this time we have the opposite effect
the 12.9 inch
is a little bit faster in this case
almost three percent faster
so maybe cooling is starting to come in
after we're doing
multiple runs but either way the metal
score
is absolutely incredible for a tablet
we're getting
insane levels of performance so now i'm
going to go ahead and close this
and we're going to run a much harder
test this is 3d marks
wildlife this time we're going to make
sure both of these are
running the extreme test and let's go
ahead and let this run
and take a look at that the scores are
identical we have
29.8 frames per second compared to 29.8
so it looks like for regular tasks
there's not much of a difference
at all but there's one more test that we
could do and that is
the extreme stress test which is a
20-minute test
that will just put these things to their
limits so let's go ahead and see
if you're doing something long-term tons
of photo exports
video exports whatever you're doing
let's see if that makes a difference
all right guys so we are finished and
the results are much more
interesting it looks like over a period
of
20 minutes we definitely have a
difference here if you look at the
stress test here
you see how quickly that drops down
levels out
and drops again whereas here it's much
more tapered on the 12.9 inch
now the best loop score we got actually
slightly higher just a little bit higher
than 11 inch
but the lowest loop score that
definitely is a bigger difference so it
looks like both these do
actually throttle over time which of
course you can expect these are super
thin
with a super powerful chip but the 12.9
inch performs about 10 percent
better once you actually heat this thing
up and as far as stability
that is also about 10 percent different
slightly more than that
so it looks like if you're somebody that
pushes the machine
to the extreme for a long period of time
maybe some productivity
or even maybe gaming once we have games
that can take advantage of
these cpus you will get better
performance about 10
better performance with a 12.9 inch now
i do have to say
that i think that most people will not
have an issue and you should not choose
the larger one
because of better performance or just
because of the better performance
because the m1 in this 11 inch is still
super powerful even when it throttles
down and now it's time for probably the
biggest difference that you guys have
been waiting for and that is
the lcd display compared to mini led
instead of having one backlight system
the 12.9 inch has apple's new
xdr system which has 2 500 or so
different
zones of tiny leds that can adjust by
themselves and we're gonna look at some
hdr footage and also blooming
which could be and is an issue with this
but because this display apple raised
the base price
of the 2.9 inch by another hundred
dollars compared to last year
so is it worth it now first i want to
test out the brightness and see
can this new thousand it or up to 1600
nits of brightness
outshine the 600 nit regular ipad
when you're actually adjusting it
yourself but the first thing that i
noticed
is that although i set both these to 50
using siri
so they automatically perfectly adjusted
if you look at him
from an off angle you guys could
probably tell the 11 inch with the lcd
panel
is much much dimmer so that top camera
is directly above
they look pretty much identical but from
the side and from
down here there's a massive difference
so the viewing angles
on the new mini led display they are
just much better
and as far as the maximum brightness i
went ahead and adjusted that top camera
so it doesn't blow out and they look
exactly
identical so even though this one's
rated up to 1
600 nits compared to 600 which is a
massive difference
in reality the brightness is the same
and apple actually says that in their
fine print
the extra brightness is only used for
hdr
so now with that said let's go ahead and
close this
and take a look at some hdr footage now
these kind of things are always really
hard
to show off on camera because we're not
recording or displaying an hdr
but i'm going to do my best to just
explain the differences and right now i
set that camera to about an average
exposure
so this could be getting blown out but
taking a look at the video footage
the electricity right there is just
coming out so much
brighter it's much more vibrant but at
the same time the darker areas are also
a little bit darker
which i don't know if i'm a fan of at
least in this brighter room environment
bam not lighting right there it just it
flashes it really stands out
compared to being kind of flat looking
here and
wow that stands out right there i'm
worried that it's just blown out for you
guys but to my eyes it looks incredible
and the image is definitely better at
least
with you know scenes like this in this
kind of a lighting and
right there wow that is popping way more
so it looks like four movies like
avengers where you have a lot of color
you have specific really bright areas
this hdr effect it just works really
well and it gives the image a lot more
dynamics i guess i should say but then
again we are watching in the daytime
there's another difference
between these two and that is contrast
so let's go ahead and shut off the
lights
alright wow look at that difference now
this
is much more dramatic now we have
the black bars here i went ahead and i
zoomed back out so you can see the black
bars
this is gray here clearly great compared
to
pitch black and not only that
but the actual contrast of the image
you're watching let me zoom in here
again
the mini led looks really nice really
contrasty oh my goodness that is bright
you guys probably can't tell the
difference because both of them are
bright but this
really stands out all right if you're
watching movies
in a dark environment or youtube videos
the difference is much bigger and here's
probably an even better difference this
is an
oled test on youtube look at the
difference in contrast
once it's dark in your room if you're
watching a movie or hdr video on youtube
the difference is absolutely shocking
at least at these brighter levels now
with that not everything is great about
mini led displays
you guys may have heard of the blooming
issues that people
are talking about with this new 12.9
inch and that
is when you see a glow around edges of
bright objects on dark backgrounds now
the most extreme case
is having pure black in the background
and pure bright
and then having it turned up now sitting
here right now
with this image that i downloaded
specifically to show this off
honestly at brightness that's normal
actually this probably about 75
brightness here i cannot see anything
the mini led display looks
perfect and on the 11 inch it also looks
great i could tell that the black isn't
true black
it is a little bit gray but if you go
ahead and max out that brightness
let's go ahead and do that now what can
i see well if i'm sitting at an angle
especially if i go even more
angle like this i do start seeing a
slight amount of glow around the outside
whereas with 11 inch i see that glow if
you want to call it across the whole
display
but it's less noticeable because
everything is gray instead of black
instead of just around the text now this
is with the display maxed out
which i don't need about 50 is perfect
for this environment now when this is
much more noticeable is if you shut off
the lights let me go do that
and now the blooming effect from the
zones is much more apparent
now from the top down view if i'm
holding it correctly it is still
minor surprisingly with that white being
so bright
and then if i look from an angle i see
it much
more and that's what some of the photos
that i saw online
when it's off an angle and then it's
also what kind of camera you're using
that comes into effect
and it's up to you do you want to deal
with a little bit of blooming and the
worst cases scenarios
which are not very likely or do you want
to have a display that is
very great in those exact same scenarios
that choice is yours now if you want to
know more about this we
actually did a dedicated video seeing
if this blooming issue is an actual
issue or not
and we show off a lot of different use
cases real world scenarios
so you guys can check that video out
after this one and now it's time for
the verdict should you buy the 11 inch
or should you buy the 12.9 inch
and for me the choice is really easy
if you're somebody that is mostly using
your tablet as a tablet
and you're doing some productivity and
you're budget conscious
i would definitely go for the 11 inch
even though i love the xdr display the
mini led display looks fantastic
but the portability of this ipad packed
with that performance and the fact that
it costs
hundred dollars less and the keyboard
case comes in at fifty dollars less for
the smaller one
makes this such a great value and
personally i would take it with me
much more often and use it for a variety
of tasks
than the 12.9 inch which is much bigger
and bulkier
now for this one if you're somebody is
doing a ton of productivity
and you know you need that larger size
and the extra weight doesn't matter you
still
will use it then in that case i would
get the 12.9 inch
and of course along with that the very
very few of you out there
that want to work with hdr content
you're doing hdr video editing
or hdr photo editing which is now
starting to become a thing
you absolutely have to have the xdr
mini led display without that you cannot
do hdr editing so the 11 inch will not
work for that
but for most people although this
display is amazing
i would stick with the 11 inch of course
we have links to both these down in the
description
and you guys can go ahead and check out
the other great videos i mentioned right
over there
and click above to subscribe if you
enjoy this video that will help us out
and help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers
before the end of the year that would be
absolutely amazing this max and i'll see
you in the next video